hey film courage my name is free go
Bradley errands I'm 18 years old and
yeah let's jump into it all right
whenever I have some time free I will go
and I will write or I'll be always
thinking of ideas and if I don't think
I've got enough done in one day I'll
then work into the night to make sure i
get enough hours done there's never a
day where I don't work on the script so
I have hours and hours on it every day
which is so so fun why haven't you quit
on the script I really like this
question actually for me it's it's right
now it's some my passion sort of or the
flag for it so what I stand for so no i
won't wait on that one day I'll just
really frustrating I said you know what
I got to stop brain myself into these
corners if I can't get out of them and
so I came up with this kind of rule of
thumb that if you write yourself in the
corner the only way you can get out of
that corner is to write your way out you
can't just throw it away it's not an
option one lesson that screenwriting is
taught me is that anything can be
imagined and if you can imagine
something and you can come up with a
story around it you can make you real
and that's a big passion of mine because
there's a lot of things in the world
that people just wish you could do and
if it wasn't for film and if it wasn't
for screenwriting and writers you
wouldn't have that visual false and you
wouldn't be able to imagine the things
that we wish we could when I actually
either feel most inspired when I'm super
tired or when I've read something really
bad and I just get this urge to write
the best that I can that's that's really
it really but as far as actually giving
you end up paper it I really have to
schedule that because if I don't
schedule it I i procrastinate you know I
lose interest in certain scenes I I I
just worked with this slow so that's
something that should be helping me as a
screenwriter is the scheduled time for
myself so that I do not let myself
procrastinate so thanks for watching I
really hope you enjoyed it and I can't
wait to get back from you guys i really
enjoy your channel and i think this is
awesome when you guys are doing
keep writing every single day